today on the matt wall show the people
who've been calling us nazis for decades
are now concerned that groomer is a
vicious unfair label after years of
labeling everyone in sight they're
finally getting a taste of their own
medicine and they don't like it the only
difference is that unlike nazi the
groomer label is actually true we'll
talk about that also the pro-life group
that blew the whistle about illegal
abortions in dc held a press conference
yesterday some of the additional details
they revealed are absolutely bone
chilling but you need to hear them plus
the only joe biden video that might
actually make you feel a little bit
sorry for him if fleetingly will play
that and if you thought woke oreos were
bad wait until you see
what the latest virtue signaling snack
company has come up with all of that and
more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
i first learned that i was a nazi many
years ago i don't remember what the
opinion was exactly but i expressed some
kind of opinion about something and i
was promptly informed that only nazis
think that way or say those sorts of
things
of course the confusing part was that my
opinion had nothing at all to do with
nazism or anything associated with
nazism
nonetheless i was a nazi and like so
many others i have relearned this lesson
every day since
these days i'm called a nazi dozens of
times every hour of every day i'm a nazi
for criticizing joe biden i'm a nazi for
opposing critical race theory i'm a nazi
for believing that men can't have babies
i'm a nazi for not wanting preschool
teachers to talk to four-year-olds about
their sexuality i'm a nazi for saying
that fat people should consider dieting
i'm a nazi for preferring vanilla ice
cream over chocolate etc and so forth on
and on forever
and i'm not just a nazi again as so many
of you have learned about yourselves i'm
also every ist and phobe in the book i'm
a sexist a transphobe a homophobe a fat
phobe a misogynist an ableist a fascist
a white supremacist and so on
every week i learned that i'm guilty of
new moral crimes that i didn't even know
existed before last week i was a
a massage noir which apparently is a
racist misogyny a racist racist misogyny
against black women as misogynor and i'm
guilty of that too it turns out
my super villain resume continues to
grow
i am indeed the worst nazi white
supremacist fat phobe ableist anti-gay
fascist transphobic misogynoris
misogynist homophobe the world has ever
seen
along with all the other nazi white
supremacists fat phobe ableist anti-gay
fascists transphobic misogynoris
misogynist homophobes there are a lot of
us out there half the country if not
more
at least that's what we have been told
that's how we've been labeled
we've been labeled this way relentlessly
non-stop in response to literally every
view we hold everything we say
every argument we make and every opinion
we express
so you must forgive me if i am not very
sympathetic to the leftists who are now
complaining about being labeled groomers
these are the very people who have hung
every smear slur and label under the sun
around my neck and yours for decades
they've literally accused us of being
secret agents of the third reich and now
they insist that we
should be more careful with the labels
that we use
your accusations are unfair and hurtful
you damn nazi klansmen
they say as they wipe tears away
so you'll excuse me if i struggle to
take their emotions seriously
and yet this is the response they're
going with
over the last several days in response
especially to conservative criticism of
contanji jackson's lenience towards
pedophiles and our push for parental
rights in florida and elsewhere
the media have declared that grooming
accusations are unfair despicable
shameful
the kinds of things that only nazis say
the washington post has an article
headlined the new red scare the right
leans into pedophilia accusations
and then vice declares conservatives are
smearing don't say gay opponents as
pedophile groomers
the weak wonders why are republicans so
concerned about grooming
uh because it's bad i think probably
just answer it that way
new york magazine has a long piece
explaining quote why republicans are
smearing everyone as pedophiles now
josh marshall at talking points memo
goes farther he says that
the groomer accusation is quote
pre-genocide talk so now we're genocidal
but we're the ones again we should be
careful with the labels right
and there's of course round agreement
that the grooming claims are really
thinly veiled homophobia as the daily
beast explains in their article
republicans say groomer to put a nice
face on homophobia
that article by the way written by
daniel summers says in part read a
little bit of this too it says by
reaching for the language of sexual
predation to be wielded against lgbtq
plus people and our supporters in
decrying this law
people calling us groomers make plain
that the hatred never really left
the same hideous lies that inform the
taunts of my childhood bullies are near
at hand for use today
of course what we really want is nothing
like the vicious falsehood imputed to us
i don't want my own young children
learning about sex straight or gay or
otherwise before it's developmentally
appropriate any more than any other
parent does
what i do want is for them to be able to
talk about their two dads in the same
easy way their peers with heterosexual
parents talk about their families and
for their teachers to be able to
participate in guiding those discussions
if necessary i want families like ours
to show up in the books available in my
class or in the classrooms so both my
kids and the other students can see that
we exist alongside them
i want kids who don't conform to other
people's gender expectations to be safe
and supported in their classrooms just
the way they are
once again
um they are the ones who assume that any
accusation of grooming must be a
reference to lgbt people
and we never said that perhaps this
writer has some guilt on his own
conscience that makes him leap to that
conclusion i have no idea what i do know
is that all the florida bill does and
all that any of us are calling for as it
relates to this topic is a prohibition
of sexually inappropriate classroom
instruction that's it
we are not saying that gay people are
the only ones who give this kind of
inappropriate instruction we don't care
who's giving it
the who is not important
it's the what
and as for that what the writer claims
that he agrees that children shouldn't
learn about sex before it's
developmentally appropriate but then in
the next sentence
he says that he wants teachers to guide
discussions about his children's two
dads
now there's nothing in the bill
preventing his children from talking
about their home life but
why do you need the teachers to guide
that discussion and what does that mean
i don't recall any of my teachers in any
grade in any classroom guiding
discussions about our personal lives
the phrasing here is quite bizarre and
it leads inevitably to the conclusion
that in fact he does want teachers
giving sexually uh inappropriate
instruction to young children even as he
claims otherwise
but according to the left the groomer
label is not only a vicious hurtful
smear
it's also of course a conspiracy theory
chris hayes on msnbc laid this out uh
last night listen to this
these republican politicians and their
allies in conservative media cannot just
come out and say
there is an evil cabal of liberals
running a child sex trafficking ring
around the world dominated by george
soros the rothschilds and the clintons
and they also worship satan they realize
they sound nuts
so instead they find these not-so-clever
ways to play ftse with the people that
do believe that that make up at least a
quarter of the base of their party
like
accusing judge jackson of being
sympathetic to child abusers wink wink
or adopting the slogan
save the children which of course sounds
perfectly noble innocent enough on its
face but as associate press reports has
actually become a dog whistle to q anon
supporters
or more recently through vague
allegations of grooming an age-old smear
to imply that members of lgbtq community
are trying to prime children for sexual
abuse
that appears to be the case in florida
and the basis behind the state's
so-called don't say gay bill which
prohibits the discussion the discussion
in class of sexual orientation or gender
identity
in classrooms for young children
just to clarify one thing first of all
um
we are not saying that liberals and
democrats
worship satan uh they are satanists yes
but they worship themselves and satanism
is the worship of the self so but yeah i
mean absolutely satanic they they are
and so are you chris hayes
that's all a dog whistle to q anon uh he
says never mind that at this point q
anon is comprised of about four people
posting memes back and forth on a
message board somewhere
the irony is that hayes demonstrates the
leftist propensity for smearing and
labeling their opponents even while
decrying the alleged smearing and
labeling of his own side
he says that anybody wants to save the
children or who opposes inappropriate
sexual discussion in kindergarten is a
proponent of the q anon conspiracy
theory
and they're also nazis of course
meanwhile even some alleged
conservatives have locked arms with
leftists like chris hayes in an attempt
to shield them from the groomer tag
david french of course
um
usual suspect posted an article titled
against the groomer smear now i didn't
read it because it's behind a paywall
that i'm definitely not paying for but
we can assume that french's argument
boils down to this tweet that he sent
out earlier the same day he says
redefining grooming and slinging false
accusations of sympathy for pedophilia
is pure malice blue checks doing it on
this website know better but lots of
ordinary folks don't
they hear the words and apply their
ordinary meaning
that's incredibly dangerous
this is malice it's dangerous
inappropriate
that's david french's whole career at
this point is whacking his finger and
saying in a inappropriate
now you have to love this from david
french it's it's the perfect mix of
whimpish cow towing hypocritical
dishonesty and pompous paternalism
ordinary folks are too stupid to
understand what is meant by groomer he
says
he's standing up for those ordinary
folks who are just morons
and his sentiments are echoed by others
that allege conservative publications
like the dispatch and bulwark um you
can't be surprised to see these folks
taking this position i mean they
represent a brand of conservatism that
has achieved nothing of significance i
mean it has presided over the left's
total domination of the culture
it has watched haplessly and helplessly
as left-wing radicals took over every
major cultural institution to include
and especially the educational
institutions
it has at best slowed our civilizational
descent into the abyss but probably not
even managed that much
and now that it sees a brand of
conservatism that is actually landing
some blows here you know winning back
some of the ground that was lost
ever so slowly ever so
you know um
inch by inch
now that it sees this brand of
conservative achieving what it could
never achieve
the proponents of this ineffectual
effeminate brand of conservatism perhaps
out of envy or simply weakness or some
combination
they run to the left
becoming outright defenders of what they
had previously spent decades pretending
to oppose
they hate the groomer label especially
because it works
and these faux conservatives hate
nothing so much as what actually works
and that's what we have to understand
about groomer the label
first of all even if the label was
unfair
the people complaining about its
unfairness have no room to complain
their tears mean nothing
they have smeared and lied and slandered
and defamed with abandon for years on
end
they're now getting a dose of their own
medicine and if that's the case
and they don't like it they have only
themselves to blame
but as it happens
the label is not unfair
it is simply an undeniable fact
that leftist radicals in education and
in media and in hollywood and in
government are now and have been for
years indoctrinating and grooming kids
into a certain sexual view and lifestyle
that is precisely how lgbt and trans
identifications have increased
exponentially in just a short period of
time
that is why there's now an epidemic of
kids confused about their genders that's
why the identity crisis has gotten so
bad that they're putting litter boxes in
public school bathrooms for kids who
identify as felines
this is all the result of grooming
it's what they're doing
it's what they've done
and they hate it when we point it out
which is why we must continue to do so
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
okay we'll start uh
back with this
i want to call it a disturbing story but
disturbing doesn't even begin to cover
it but it is a it is a story that should
be covered and is not being covered by
especially the mainstream outlets so
this is from the daily wire the latest
u.s lawmakers are calling on washington
d.c mayor muriel bowser and department
of justice to investigate the abortions
of five babies whose bodies were
allegedly recovered by pro-life
activists from an abortion clinic in a
letter exclusively obtained by the daily
wire republican lawmakers remind bowers
or rather bowser and attorney general
merrick garland
that the babies deserve to have their
deaths investigated to ensure that no dc
or federal laws were broken the bodies
were allegedly recovered by members of
the progressive anti-abortion uprising
group who said they intercepted a box
with dismembered babies before it was
sent to a medical waste center
and now
several
elected republicans
are um
are including marsha blackburn mike lee
josh hawley and others are
we are
demanding
that the department of justice
investigate this
and also dc on the local level
because if this was partial birth
abortion and we're gonna play some clips
here in a minute which indicate that
that at least in some cases it was
then that is a federal crime
and by the way maybe you see how the the
dots are connected here because
one thing you hear about partial birth
abortion which as i explained i think
yesterday that is the
just as the name implies that is
aborting killing a child
as it is being born when it is partially
born when the child is partially born uh
he is killed with you know as long as
part of his body is still inside the
birth canal then he's killed and
for so long we were we've been told that
uh well that never happens
you know no such thing as happening
that's that this is this is ridiculous
another conspiracy theory
well yeah it it doesn't officially
happen if you refuse to prosecute it if
you ignore it then it quote never
happens
and so we are seeing this in real time
this almost certainly at least some of
these babies were the vic they were all
the victim of murder let's be clear
about that but
almost some some of them were almost
certainly the victim of partial birth
abortion if not post birth abortion
infanticide
um but the refusing the police are
refusing to investigate it
and so it's not going to count
in the record books
yet another example of a partial birth
abortion that did occur
almost certainly but doesn't count and
so they can say well it never happens
and
given the
ex extraordinary lengths that this
pro-life group had to go through
in order just to reveal that this
happened
i mean they had to
obtain the bodies themselves
put themselves in legal jeopardy
in order to do it
and then post pictures of those bodies
and even after doing all of that still
the police refused to investigate my
question is
um how many children
have fallen victim to this crime but we
don't even hear about it
because there isn't any pro-life group
that was was able to go to those lengths
or willing to do it
so yesterday the progressive
anti-abortion uprising group held a
press conference and um
we're gonna go through some of the clips
of from this press conference we'll
start
kind of in a sequential order here
first here they are
describing the scene when they um attain
this
box of dead bodies and uh just listen to
this
in the presence of a catholic deacon
lorn cut open the box and the red
plastic bag inside
we then proceeded to unpack the remains
of 110
mostly first trimester aborted children
at the bottom of the box was a clear
plastic bag with five more containers
one much bigger than the remaining four
lauren reached into the largest bucket
and removed the remains of a beautiful
intact and nearly full term baby boy who
we named christopher x
i think i can speak for both lauren and
i when i say this was the most
devastating and soul-crushing experience
of our lives
not even years of anti-abortion advocacy
could have prepared us for that moment
and it's a moment that will live on for
us for all of time
we continued to open the larger
containers and discovered four more
babies with a range of injuries
including fully intact girl we named
harriet who had one eye open
an incision in the back of her her neck
her brain suctioned out and her skull
crushed
two other late term babies named angel
and holly were severely dismembered
and the final baby phoenix was whole and
still inside the amniotic sac
know we hear so much about people uh
suffering trauma because of mean tweets
or whatever we heard about the
journalists the female journalist taylor
lorenz gets some mean tweets people
criticizing the shoddy work that she
does and she's traumatized for that she
can barely sleep at night um
well no this is this is what actual
trauma is i mean this is this is
traumatic if you can imagine i don't
even want to imagine
uh these women who are heroes by the way
this is also what her heroism looks like
going through this box of dead children
literally a box of dead children and one
of those children had her brain sucked
out of her skull because this is
something that we're doing in america
um cutting holes in baby skulls and
sucking the brains out is a thing that's
happening in the united states of
america right now currently
and
yeah you might not have noticed
because all the most powerful
institutions in our culture don't want
you to notice
and they go through considered effort to
make sure that you don't find out about
it
again this is this is what had to have
this is what these people had to do just
so that some of us hear about this
and even this is not enough apparently
to ensure that any justice is actually
done
but most people aren't hearing about it
and and uh and most people in america
right now for the last few weeks have
been more more focused on and concerned
about atrocities in ukraine
and i'm sorry i just can't take people
seriously
when they are crying about atrocities in
ukraine
as sad as it is that terrible things are
happening in ukraine and elsewhere in
the world it is a terrible thing
and it is quite sad
but
in this course is not the case for
everybody who's concerned about ukraine
it is possible to be concerned about
both
but i have noticed that quite quite
quite a lot of people really concerned
about ukraine and the fact that babies
in this country in a major american city
in fact in a city
where the white house is
at a clinic a few miles down from the
white house babies are having their
brains sucked out of their skulls
i've just noticed that a lot of the
people concerned about those ukrainian
tragedies and atrocities have just have
absolutely nothing to say about this
and yes we should be more concerned
about this
than we are about ukraine why because
these are our children
and by that i mean american children
in our country
and also there is literally nothing
worse in the world
than butchering and dismembering and
crushing the skull of an infant child
there is no atrocity there is no war
crime that could possibly be worse than
that it is the worst of the worst it
doesn't get worse than that
it can get really really bad but that's
as bad as it gets
and it's happening right here
now later on in the press conference
they explain why they think that this um
that this is evidence not just of
abortion
which is a moral crime in its own right
but why they think this is evidence of
illegal abortions let's listen
live action captured undercover footage
of abortionist cesare santangelo the
sole abortionist on staff for decades at
washington sergey admitting that he does
not use feticide
because of this admission
and the advanced gestational ages of
these babies and their intact condition
the likelihood that some were born alive
is undeniable
additionally the injuries sustained by
harriet strongly imply she was the
victim of a partial birth abortion
so you have according to medical experts
and according to just any any rational
person who can see the evidence with
their own eyes there is very good reason
to suspect that a federal crime was
committed against these children
and the police again we cannot emphasize
enough
refuse to invest they won't even take
the time or go through the trouble of
doing an autopsy to figure out how
exactly these children died they they
looked
they looked at a box full of dead babies
and just said right away oh yeah nothing
nothing bad happened there
and dead children that they that were
given to them not by an abortion clinic
but by
a woman from the it was was had the
bodies in her townhouse
isn't that reason enough
to investigate further
are you not wondering a little bit about
that
um continuing on they talk about their
attempts to alert authorities and how
difficult that was and also the the um
striking lack of urgency
on the part of the authorities let's
listen on march 29th lauren and i
coordinated with attorneys to alert the
d.c homicide unit of the location of the
five larger babies and request an
investigation into their deaths
arrangements were made for the babies to
be picked up that evening but police
didn't arrive until the afternoon of the
30th just hours after lauren was taken
into custody by the fbi in connection
with a rescue two years prior
today i stand in solidarity with lauren
and the eight other defendants who are
facing harsh incarceration incarceration
penalties under the face act for simply
protecting the victims of violent
oppression at santangelo's clinic
and while these heroes are being
unjustly prosecuted santangelo continues
to kill babies and exploit their parents
for profit as he has done for decades
this must end
we are demanding that the dc police
conduct a full investigation into the
deaths of these babies including
thorough autopsies
we demand that the u.s department of
justice prosecutes santangelo for
violations of the born alive infant
protection act and the partial birth
abortion act
and we're demanding it now
oh well no urgency right no reason to
rush i mean the police were told about
dead bodies
that this woman lauren handy had
obtained
and they don't even show up the same day
they take their time
and they want to make sure that she's
arrested first before they even show up
to investigate
now this this of course is not actually
laziness and incompetence i mean that
might i'm sure that's part of the story
that's always part of the recipe
but um
that's not the primary motivator here
is that
they know because they are government
officials in dc they know what their
role is and it is to run cover for the
abortion clinic
and so this is again a cover-up
happening in plain sight they're barely
even trying to hide the fact that
they're covering it up
okay one more clip i want to play for
you and this is just because i think
she deserves to be heard lauren handy is
the the woman who um
is right now first of all facing federal
charges
and the woman who brought this to
everyone's attention and uh she got up
to microphone and talked a little bit
about her experiences listen
phoenix harriet christopher x angel and
holly the children who have been
featured in the news so far were so
advanced in their gestational age and
the patterns of their wounds suggest
violent federal crimes we arranged for
the medical examiner to pick up the
children
washington sergey is part of a network
of 21 abortion centers in the dmv area
the abortion industry which is the
overlapping interest of state and
business
use fear isolation and violence to make
off
make profit off of people who are
pregnant
families and in particular low income
women facing crisis and unwanted
pregnancies
uplifting and showing the five children
does not pit us against their parents i
am deeply heartbroken for these families
their exploitation from washington
surging
and then their children being used for
profit by curtis bay
shows how deeply flawed our communities
are structured
well uh we're not gonna have time to do
the whole five headlines but but i
wanted to make sure that we
spent time on this issue um
and
it's
i guess i don't know how else to say it
other than they're sucking the brains
out of babies in washington dc right now
it's that's a thing that's happening
and they're also covering up the crime
now the next headline i think kind of
relates and it ties everything together
because we've talked about cowardly
conservatives ineffectual conservatives
don't do anything and we've also talked
about the atrocities of abortion so
let's bring all that together and then
we have this from the hill senator mitt
romney who hails from one of the most
conservative states in the country
announced monday that he will vote for
judge kintanji brown jackson to serve as
the first black woman on supreme court
and praised her as a person of honor
romney who of course voted twice to
convict former president trump on
impeachment charges
uh said after reviewing judge jackson's
record and testimony i have concluded
that she is a well qualified jurist and
a person of honor while i do not expect
to agree with every decision she may
make on the court i believe that she
more than meets the standard of
excellence and integrity
according to his statement
her dedication to public service and her
family are obvious and also i enjoyed
our meeting he says well he enjoyed the
meeting and he liked talking to her so
why not vote for her
is she a person of honor and integrity
well we know that she's not and i don't
even need the fact that she does have an
obvious record
of being lenient on child predators and
pedophiles
that is another fact that is undeniable
child rapists child pornographers
got oftentimes the
the most lenient possible penalty
under the law from judge jackson that's
that's we don't even need to go there to
establish the fact that she's not a
person of honor because she's
pro-abortion and she's in favor of
protecting the quote right to murder
babies
and it is impossible to be a person of
honor i don't care what else you've done
in your life i don't care what what
other facts there are about you
i don't care if you're a loving wife and
it doesn't doesn't matter you cannot be
an honorable person
while not only supporting the murder of
babies but actually working to ensure
that those that the right to murder is
protected
it should there are things in life that
you can do
um
where you totally forfeit all of your
honor and dignity and that's one of
those
that's also another reason why if you
call yourself a pro-life conservative
you cannot possibly vote
for katanji brown jackson
again leaving aside even all the child
porn leniency
that that yeah that's that would also be
a reason not to vote for but you know we
don't even need to get there because we
know that she supports murdering babies
and wants to protect that right
yeah mitt romney while calling himself a
pro-lifer is going to vote for her
um okay there's some more dc politics on
a little bit of a lighter note although
this is
also um
probably one of the cringiest videos
you'll see obama was at the white house
yesterday for an event having to do with
the 12th anniversary of obamacare being
rammed down the throats of the american
people
and um he doesn't he doesn't associate
with joe biden very much he's it's it's
conspicuous how
little he has said in defense of biden
and uh how few times we've seen him like
this is actually the first time since
joe biden was present that we've seen
the two of them together maybe aside
from the inauguration but he was there
um mostly because it was about him it
was about celebrating his own supposed
accomplishments but after they did their
speech or whatever it was there was a
period of mingling
and uh and then this happened everyone's
talking about this let's play the video
we see uh
joe biden
[Music]
they're all standing around and mingling
and everyone just flocks to obama
ignoring the president united states and
now he's standing there looking around
on the outside of the of the talking
circle
and this video is even worse because
joe biden he doesn't want to be on the
outside he's actually grabbing
obama trying to get his attention and
obama just completely ignores him
i actually i i gotta say i i uh
if there was ever anything that could
make me feel sorry for joe biden
slightly maybe just temporarily it would
be this
oh that's rough
that is rough and i feel for biden a
little bit
i understand what's happening i mean
this is what happens to me at events if
i do any event with with ben shapiro
this is like this is like backstage live
at the ryman the vip meet and greet you
know i'm joe biden in that scenario
everyone's flocking to so i understand
actually it's something kind of
universal
that i think we've all been if you've
been in a social situation at a party or
something biden made a strategic mistake
and you've probably been through this
before you're at a social function
and um this is my move anyway when
you're at the social function
if i if i ever if i get cornered into
having to be in a social i try to avoid
them as much as i can but if i have to
be at one
mainly because my wife or the daily wire
forces me into it um
what you want to do is you want to find
your your circle like you got to find a
talking circle and just stick with your
circle
ingratiate yourself into a circle of
people talking and just stay there
biden made the mistake of walking away
from his circle and then he couldn't get
back in he was the odd man out just
wandering around
that can happen or you could get edged
out of the circle by a new person who
comes in
the worst thing that can happen though
is that you have your circle and there's
like five people including you in the
circle and then three of them
walk away leaving you with just one
other person and it's the one person you
have the least to say to you have
nothing in common with them
and now it's like do we have to have a
one-on-one conversation or do we both
awkwardly walk away from this
so i get it i'm going to defend biden
just on that
at least
this is my one defense of joe biden is
that
all right i want to play this for you is
this perhaps the dumbest
and cringiest woke corporate virtue
signal of all time and i know that's
saying something we had oreos yesterday
you know oreos putting an ad out uh
about a uh an asian
kid coming coming out as gay to his
grandmother
nothing to do with oreos whatsoever no
attempt to even circle it back
to uh to oreos
well now another snack food has gotten
in on the action this is from the daily
wire it says the makers of cracker jack
uh of course the caramel popcorn snack
popular baseball stadiums and
prominently featured in the classic
baseball anthem take me out to the
ballgame is receiving a woke repackaging
including a rewriting of the song with a
gender equality message
so they have rebranded themselves as not
cracker jack but cracker jill
and they wrote on their website
sometimes all it takes to believe you
can do something is to see someone who
looks like you do it first
it's in this spirit that cracker jack
proudly introduces cracker jill a team
of new faces showing girls that they're
represented
even in our most iconic snacks i
understand the need for this
okay i i can't i can't i'll never forget
the first time
i was in the snack aisle with uh with my
daughter and she saw the cracker jack
box and she just broke down in tears
she saw cracker jack and she said to me
daddy does this mean that
that i can't pursue my own dreams
and i said to her yeah it does that's
exactly what it means
but now that they've rebranded the
cracker jill i can go home and i can
tell the news to my daughter
that you see they rebranded the cracker
jelly so you can do anything that you
want in your life
don't all women look to
snack companies for their inspiration
and motivation in life
well this is about to get really
inspiring because as mentioned they
rebranded the song to take me out to a
ball to the ball game to give a little
bit of a feminist bent
and uh let's listen to that
take me out to the ball
game
take me out
buy me some peanuts and crack a chill
no one can stop you if you have the
wheelcholes
dream we're adding our
[Music]
play ball
that's a tough one
that's a tough one that's eve that's
even harder to get through than the joe
biden video
crackerjill.com you can go
now this is if they expect that people
are going to start actually singing that
at baseball games there is less chance
of that than there is that hispanic
people actually start calling themselves
latinx there's even less chance that
that's going to happen
and i
i don't need to say it i know but i but
i have to
because this is all about defending
women's sports they say or it's about
encouraging women well
what is that exactly
and it's it's kind of interesting timing
that now they've decided to come out
uh
about women's sports when there is only
one threat against women's sports and
it's from the trans agenda there are no
other threats
but we can assume that cracker jill is
uh they're not trying to make any
statement about that we can assume that
let's get to the comment
[Music]
off the section with rage
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
all right uh lol has matt ever given
relationship advice that didn't end with
just break up
that is usually my advice because it's
pretty simple advice but but also
and that it's it's important to clarify
that's only advice i give to people who
are not married i mean if you're married
then that's not gonna be my advice
but
i think it boils down to this and this
is an important thing to know if you're
if you're dating
you you shouldn't be having major
problems
maybe not everyone agrees with this
might be controversial
but i would say you should not be having
major relationship problems in the
dating phase
you just
started dating
um
many times you you're just getting to
know each
other you still have all of the you know
you should still be in that kind of
honeymoon phase even though you're not
even married yet
but uh you're actually in sort of the
infatuation stage which is supposed to
by there's a there's a biological reason
for that it's supposed to propel you to
the altar and you're still in that phase
and in that phase when everything is
fresh and new if you're already having
serious problems with each other then um
then it's just it's it's it's not worth
it you've got those are the red flags
and the great thing is you're just
dating so you can both just walk away
from it you don't even have you don't
need to have a big conversation about it
the other person might want you to but
you don't need to there's no obligation
for that
you could send a text message and just
say we're done
you have zero
responsibility to them zero
um
that's my inspirational message for you
west says
we didn't put ourselves in this
situation matt we were put in it i
assume you mean culturally
um
uh
i know we like to tell ourselves that
but the fact is that look we're all
we're all a part of the culture we're
all a part of this country and so
yeah we can blame the institutions
the powerful institutions who brought us
to this point and they deserve a lot of
the blame
but my question is
where were conservatives
for years and years when the education
institution was being invaded and taken
over by by radicals where were they on
this
i know in the last couple of years were
very clued into this problem and
actually doing something about it
but you know why not 20 years ago
so now we might want to console
ourselves by saying that this was all
foisted upon us and we're victims of it
but the fact is we at least
when i say we i mean generally
we're cooperators
in our silence
um
chris says you're better at commercials
than ben his style of segueing into it
is always hilarious there's no way ben
is that bad at commercials
that i'm better than it's not possible i
don't believe it
um
let's see your your mouth boyfriend
whatever that means says kids will ask
about literally anything to get out of
school it's up to the adult to regulate
these questions and deflect them so that
the kids focus on their lessons instead
that's a very good point and it reminded
me because i said that i've said
multiple times when i was in school we
never talked about the teacher's private
life and that's true
but we did talk about all kinds of
irrelevant things
if we could bait the teacher into
getting into those conversations
anything we needed to do
to make sure that no actual lesson or
instruction occurred that day and very
often the teachers were far too willing
to go along with our efforts to distract
and derail everything just so that we
didn't have to do any actual work
and that's also when you see these kids
who are doing walkouts over the don't
say gay bill or whatever it is um yeah
there's
a lot of that is because they've been
indoctrinated and brainwashed but also
it's because
they get to walk out rather than go to
class
so that's something we have to keep in
mind as well
well did you notice anything different
about my show today now i'm not talking
about the obvious change to the set
behind me that you were all complaining
about yesterday
uh which i understand justifiable
i'm talking about the lack of ads in
today's episode well i know my youtube
and audio podcast listeners love my
flawless ad reads i know it's one of the
highlights it's just how deathly i
maneuver
and uh weave it in to the content i know
it's something you all look forward to
but
you probably enjoyed that this today
anyway the content was uninterrupted
that's what daily wire members have to
look forward to every day so if you love
the uninterrupted content and would like
to experience all the daily wire shows
this way go become a member right now at
dailywire.com subscribe and use code to
build the future to get 45 off of your
subscription plus if you've got a daily
wire member you get a discount on all of
my merch at the swag shack including my
new yeah i'm keeping that swag shack
thing going my new what is a woman
t-shirt you also get access to all of
our opinion pieces and articles and
depending which membership level you
choose you get access to our entire
content library which includes our
feature films television shows and more
and most importantly you'll be a part of
a very important mission creating a
space for everyone especially our kids
so go to dailywire.com subscribe right
now pick the membership plan that is
right for you and use build the future
to get 45 off today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so it was announced this week that joe
biden will extend the pause on student
debt payments for another several months
now if this sounds like a repeat of a
story you've heard before it's because
it is the pause was put into effect two
years ago as a pandemic relief strategy
it was then extended and extended again
and again and again
and then again and i think again
biden has for now found an end run
around the student loan forgiveness
issue
he had pledged during the campaign to
cancel
at least a portion of student debt he of
course doesn't want to actually make
good on that promise because it would be
wildly justifiably unpopular with a huge
portion of the american public
after all as i've tried to explain many
times
you cannot actually cancel student debt
any more than you could cancel my
mortgage what you can do is transfer the
burden somewhere else
in this case the burden would be
transferred from the people who
purchased the product
to the people who did not
the college graduate who purchased the
education and ostensibly supposedly
benefits from it will be relieved of the
responsibility to pay for it while
people who did not purchase the
education and will not benefit from it
will be saddled with the duty to fulfill
to fulfill the obligations of a contract
that they never signed
this sort of plan
may be popular with the people who make
out like literal bandits
but most of the rest of the country
feels differently
especially when you consider that so
many people
made enormous financial sacrifices in
order to pay off their loans
only to now discover what that they were
suckers they were patsies
they could have just refused to pay and
benefited from the government's magic
wand abracadabra act making it all
disappear
will they get a refund
probably not
what this all means is that the by
administration would prefer to pretend
that they never broached the subject
they never made this prominent promise
extending the pause indefinitely is
their way out they think
the problem is that the radicals in his
party have noticed this maneuver and are
not happy about it
in recent weeks the squad and also the
squad's grandmother elizabeth warren
have ratcheted up the pressure for a
full loan forgiveness
yesterday bernie sanders tweeted simply
cancel student debt all of it now i've
explained why canceling student debt is
not so much a bad idea as an impossible
idea it's a non-idea
the real idea transferring the debt to a
third party is the bad idea
but rather than harping on that some
more i'd like to focus on the question
of how we ended up in this situation to
begin with
there are many guilty parties
many bad guys in the story of the
student debt bubble
the universities that charge exorbitant
tuition rates for an increasingly
worthless education should be the first
in line to absorb the blame i think but
it's a long line the government public
school systems are in this line as are
frankly the parents who often demand
that their kids go to college pressure
which is born i think as much from
their own vanity as it is from their
concern for their child's future
so we can thank all these people for 1.5
trillion dollars in student debt
but there's another group that seems to
have mostly escaped the blame
escape the public's wrath despite their
unique role in driving this totally and
absurdly unnecessary crisis
we take it for granted today that our
kids need to obtain a college degree
because so many jobs require them but
that need is in the vast majority of
cases artificial
thousands of players across of employers
across the country have chosen to
arbitrarily inflate their job
requirements often demanding that
applicants have degrees for positions
that don't actually necessitate them
and it's only getting worse
positions that didn't require any degree
20 years ago now require a bachelor's
and positions that require just a
bachelor's 20 years ago now require a
master's
soon you'll need a master's to flip
hamburgers you know if you want to uh
become a landscaper you'll need a phd in
ecology or something
obviously
some jobs really do require
additional formal schooling
nobody's suggesting that a guy with a
high school diploma should be hired off
the street to perform brain surgery or
design bridges or defend the accused in
criminal court
[Music]
but most jobs outside of science and
medicine and law have to be learned by
doing
it's not as though companies save money
on training
you know by limiting themselves to
college graduates they still have to
train the college graduates
which is no surprise because most
college graduates have little to no work
experience they've never done anything
now it might be argued that employers
look for the degree because even if it's
in dance theory or comparative religion
or if it's in my field of women's
studies
they'll say that it at least proves that
the applicant is competent and
hard-working
but it proves no such thing
i mean have you seen a college student
recently
i see no reason to conclude that college
grads are any smarter any more competent
any harder working than non-college
grads look at look at footage from
spring break
so these people are the ones that you're
saying are so much more competent and
harder working than everybody else by
the way speaking of spring break a lot
of those kids they're using their
student loans to go on spring break
and then they're going to get out of
school and and whine and say that we
need to pay for those loans which they
squandered
sorry no
no in fact i would wager that the scales
kind of tipped the other way
a 23 year old who's been working and
supporting himself since 18
has already demonstrated at a minimum
that he has the basic skills necessary
to be a functioning adult in society
he's probably also demonstrated that
he's coachable he's trainable
because he's been trained in jobs before
but a 23 year old who's been sitting in
classrooms all that time has not
demonstrated that or anything else all
the college degree proves in and of
itself is that either he had the money
to pay for a degree or he was willing to
take on the debt
why should that fact alone mean that his
resume goes to the top of the stack
we all know the truth
employers demand high price degrees for
entry level positions that a moderately
intelligent monkey could learn in less
than a week
simply out of laziness
the degree requirement is a way to call
the herd of applicants making it easier
and quicker to sift through all of it
if qualified applicants are tossed aside
that's a sacrifice the employer is
willing to make for the sake of
streamlining the process
but if it wasn't for the arbitrary
demands of these lazy hr departments
kids out of high school may not feel the
need to take on crushing debt just to
obtain a piece of paper that may only
ever function as a calling card that
prevents their resumes from being
automatically thrown in the trash
the companies that unjustly discriminate
against competent workers who lack that
piece of paper
should finally start absorbing some of
the scorn and blame
that we direct everywhere except them
yes they have every right to come up
with whatever unnecessary and expensive
and frivolous job requirement they want
but they deserve to be shamed for it
and named for it
much of the current crisis is after all
their fault
and it's why they today are the ones who
are canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2022 the
science promoting puberty blockers for
kids turns out to be funded by the
pharmaceutical companies that make the
puberty blockers for kids the libs are
trying to bring kovid back and yale
calls yours truly
a threat to democracy ahead of my speech
there with senator cruz next week check
it out on the michael knowles show